let us now go through an example suppose
that we have an unknown random variable
theta that has a uniform distribution
between 4 and 10 we observe some other
random variable X that's related to
theta according to the following model
this is the conditional distribution of
x given theta for any given value of
theta x is going to take values between
theta minus 1 and theta plus 1 and the
conditional distribution is uniform on
that range one way of thinking about
this particular observation model is
that what we observe is the true value
of theta plus some noise term and this
noise term is uniform on the range from
minus 1 to plus 1 so given a value of
theta we may observe anything because of
noise that's up to one lower or one
higher than the true value of theta and
if we take this description actually
this random variable U has this
distribution no matter what theta is
and therefore U is independent of theta
but in any case this particular
interpretation will not matter let us
see how do we proceed in Bayesian
estimation the first step is always to
put our hands on the posterior
distribution of theta and to find the
posterior we can start by first finding
the joint so let us look at the X theta
plane that's where the joint
distribution is going to live and our
first step will be to locate those
values of X and theta that are possible
given our description from this model
here we know that theta minus 1 is going
to be less than or equal to X and X is
going to be less than or equal to theta
plus 1 and we translate this into two
inequalities namely that theta is less
than or equal to X plus 1
and from here that theta is larger than
or equal to X minus one so these are the
constraints that we have on the possible
values of X and theta so here we plot
the line where theta is equal to X plus
1 and here we plot the line on which
theta is equal to X minus 1 and these
two inequalities that we got here tell
us that we need to live somewhere in
between those two lines in addition we
have the fact that theta lives between 4
and 10 and that places these two limits
as well so to summarize this shape here
is the set of all possible X's and
Thetas outside this shape the joint PDF
is going to be 0 what is it going to be
inside here well because the prior is
uniform that is it is constant and the
model is also uniform to obtain the
joint we multiply these two and since
they are constant we obtain a joint
that's also constant so the joint PDF is
equal to a constant over that set we can
easily calculate the area of this set it
is 12 so the joint is equal to 1 over 12
inside this set and of course it's 0
elsewhere so we have a uniform joint PDF
now let us look at the posterior if I
tell you that X takes on this specific
value this means that we now live in
this universe and it means that all of
those Thetas are possible the posterior
distribution is going to be distribution
that tells us the probabilities of these
different Thetas what kind of
distribution is it well we know that the
conditional is just a section out of the
joint but keeps otherwise the same shape
since the joint is constant it's
uniform over that set it means that the
posterior or the conditional is also
constant over that set so the conclusion
is that the posterior distribution of
theta is a uniform distribution on this
set given this knowledge what is the
conditional expectation the conditional
expectation of a uniform is just the
midpoint of that uniform and so this is
going to be our estimate of theta the
conditional expectation of theta given
the observation that we have obtained
and then a similar argument applies no
matter what X we have obtained for any
given X our estimate is going to be the
midpoint of the corresponding interval
so what kind of shape do we get by doing
this by joining the midpoints it's going
to be a straight line over this region
it's also going to be a straight line
over this region except that because of
the change in shape it's going to be a
straight line with a different slope and
similarly in this region it's also going
to be a straight line with a different
slope so what have we plotted here for
any given value of x we have plotted the
corresponding conditional expectation of
theta given that value of x and as a
function of X this gives us a certain
curve and this blue curve that we have
calculated is a particular function of X
and we can think of this function G as
being our estimator so the way we're
going to be processing the data will be
that whenever we obtain an X we apply
this particular function G and we come
up with an estimate